well in this very special moment I am
overwhelmed with gratitude gratitude for
my parents for my family my friends my
collaborators for the Royal Swedish
Academy of Science and the Noble
Foundation this can be well understood
but I want to address special thanks to
those two person
it was kallenberg was my what so what is
called dr. father he brought me in to
science it taught me to be a scientist
and he explained to me that science is
something that should happen in a
society Sir John Kendrew was the first
general director of embl and he gave me
this tremendous chance to work on this
quite strange project of dealing with
water in the electron microscope so why
cryo-em because as you said we are made
out we are bags of water and bags of
water made of billion of cells which are
each one bags of water and if you remove
the water everything floating in the
cellar in the body will will condense it
will aggregate and if you are good in
arranging the specimen when removing the
water you will get fine aggregates if
you are not so good you get coarse
aggregates but aggregates you get
because fish doesn't fly so even a very
tough object like this default
bacteriophage when you drive them on the
supporting film they are in a very bad
shape
oh so people develop remarkable method
to preserve the specimen though the
water is removed one eye one certainly
one fine method is to dry the specimen
in a solution of heavy salt and the more
the water go the more the soul
concentrated at the end you have only
the particle with salt around it heavy
salt heavy metal salt which hold the
structure more or less correctly another
possibility is freeze dry you freeze the
specimen and instead of reivew removing
the water from the liquid you remove it
from the solid and it has great
advantage but if you look carefully the
head of this poor bacteriophage doesn't
look very healthy so at that time my
hero is still my hero was is Nigel
hanwen and we were working in very
parallel direction each one trying all
kind of trick to have a better
preservation of the specimen he had a
funny idea
he thought instead of drying the
specimen in in heavy metal salt heavy
metal salt is not healthy he dry them in
sugar because sugar is much better for
the material and it join his force as
you know with this guy with with Misha
and together they got this remarkable
result 99 with this then 90 degrees and
75 what am marking history another
person was very important I boosted I
moved too much
yes you have already heard all that
Bob Glaser perhaps you should stay here
[Laughter]
Bob Glaser during my PhD and so I did a
lot of work just following his steps but
the the most impressive message I got
off from him was this photograph and
this is this is but these are bacteria
quite broken' with all kind of sub
structure of the bacteria but what is
special we were working with this kind
of thing with all all our trick for
trying to better preserve the specimen
in sugar or in any other thing but here
he had it in ice in frozen ice we see
the marks of the ice but it's
beautifully preserved and having seen
that I thought oh this is better than
than anything I've seen before and this
is the future so two years later I was
invited to be group group leader at Yale
by John Kendrew with this project how to
deal with water in cryo-electron
microscopy so there is a problem though
frozen water is ice and ice is not
liquid water and it's as bad for a
biological specimen to be in ice than to
be without water but we were trying all
kind of tricks this is our high
technology device and it goes like that
we will try many many things but this is
one of the things we had a nebulizer
coming from the right here
high pressure nebulized throwing a
stream of micro droplets of water of any
kind of suspension and going through
this
all slit here the slit and here you have
a tweezer and at the top of the Twitter
you have one of this supporting film
this grid that you use a specimen order
in the electron microscope and while the
stream of droplets is going you let this
fall down in the liquid nitrogen and we
got like that things like that a nice
droplet of ice and this is
characteristic ice now we are left in
MacDowell I can't see him but he is here
thought I will do better and it put here
at here just in the liquid nitrogen here
a very small beaker with where it
condensed liquid ethane and instead of
letting the specimen fall down in liquid
nitrogen in let it fall down in liquid
ethane and so he went to the microscope
look at the object in the electron
microscope and called me hey if there is
something here and this was what this is
what we see and this is Beatrice that
this is not crystallized so we didn't
knew what this was the first ideas it's
liquid if they iterate it's a thin which
has been condensed here no it can't be
the temperature that temperature Ethan
should have been gone should they have
evaporated so we thought okay we will
let it evaporate and we will see what it
is so we turn off the cooling of the
specimen holder and we'll let it warm I
do not remember how long it last quarter
of an hour warm slowly and when we came
at minus 135 suddenly but in real little
rally in one second the drop transform
into a multi crystal that we recognize
immediately this was Q because Q because
is a different form of ice quite
conventional we had it studied before in
detail in our previous experiment and
electron diffraction told confirm it
it's ice so if you have a bit if you
have a vitreous droplet which turn into
ice you know that you had Beatrice water
ha so what do you do with that ah this
is Alastair McDowell vitrification man
great this was the first ha ha every and
I remember I said at that moment oh we
have something great truly and the
trouble with vitrification with wit
which water is that vitrification should
be impossible what does this mean
yes I will not go into the detail I will
just mention the founder of cryobiology
father basil Riya who work is you is a
Catholic priest in a very severe
Catholic congregation and he worked for
40 years in trying to produce suspended
life this means immobilizing life or in
order to obtain typically for breeding
typically and he make a lot of money
with this not for him but for his
congregation and and it was working with
very good people and those people with
him demonstrate that vitrification was
impossible at the end for
thermodynamical and complicated reason
that I am NOT going to explain in detail
so I want to speak about this man for
another reason he was born in savea's in
valise Switzerland and I start school
just very close to him in a place which
is would be here in the small village
just on the other side of the
here and at present we have still nice
chalet here nice mountain her here and
for those who like love mountains this
is the so-called panel this is that
oblong beautiful mountain okay so so
having our vitrification we send it for
publication and we got rapidly this
answer no you
it was reject that you can't spend
nature and they were wrong they were all
wrong for two reasons the first one is
that while they were rejecting our paper
they had under impress the paper by
Berger and Meyer who was who was proving
that obtaining complete vitrification in
pure liquid water and dilute aqueous
solution that means they made the
discovered the discovery of that matura
fication is possible and then it was
they were doubly wrong because
vitrification is very easy that's and
with our method
it was reproducible rapid and no problem
so so what do you do with that first
conclusion Mitra SWAT is not simple it's
not just liquid water immobilized in the
same shape no no it's something else
but doesn't matter it's it works so well
for cryo-electron microscopy that we
don't dare to go into the detail though
when we will go into the detail we will
certainly understand very important
things about water that we yet don't
know and perhaps it will be important
for biology also ii haha came can be
explained like that we work with these
grids and on the grids we have a thin
thin film and we spread the specimen
solution on the grid but this is
difficult because water has high surface
tension and what won't
to want water is to form a sphere
minimize the surface and trying to
maximize the surface on a grid is just
technically difficult you have to
arrange the surface so that too high
number just come equally in negative one
to Eve and the other it's a complicated
process and my collaborator Macario at
that time he died unfortunately very
badly after very stupidly after this
retirement and this is a very remarkable
person
it is very stubborn
extraordinary cultivated and it has an
enormous culture and very stubborn and
it was not at all interested in
spreading the water water on the grid so
he wanted to have no support and he was
sorry he was working trying to get the
specimen on the holes of the grid
without support
I was quite opposed to that because
there is no chance but because I knew
the physics but he did he got that and
it turns out that it was not so it was
quite easy very easy in fact and this is
a typical example on hole of the on the
hole of the grid which is 20 micrometer
broad he get this tenth of my tenths of
micrometer thick layer spreading over
the whole grid so the film is 200 times
thinner than broad technically in term
of energy it's quite strange but it
works well later
we understood why there are interesting
energy and thermodynamic reason which
explain all that but at that time we
were not aware of that so the method and
now comes the most difficult part of the
seminar well I hope this is how it
should go so you have a grid a grid on a
tweezer
you have a beaker with liquid nitrogen
you have liquid ethane and that op salut
P we try again ah
before you came with the blotting paper
as you explained in one second to grid
the liquid disappear in the oh yes the
what the water disappear goes in the
blotting paper and but the last tenth of
a micron takes another second to go away
and you have time to let the grid fall
down and get the sample get which we
fight this was 18 9 1984 this was
rapidly published whether the the
general director of embl was a new
person and it was not leather philipson
and he was not very happy with those
physicists working with water and but so
we worked with his pet virus the
adenovirus and when he got this nice
photograph he was convinced and we
became the best friend in the world and
and so was it and you notice but of
course you have heard more and you will
heard hear much more from him in a
moment when you have the particle
floating in water in all with all
orientation you can make 3d
reconstruction and so we had this 1986
this model of virus at 35 angstrom
resolution 35 mm resolution that's that
was that so came the beautiful word blob
ball orgy blob barrage yes this is
blotchy
and then a lot of people continue to
work we're working before we were also
working but those were those you
understand were very where are they more
important than the other I guess yes but
they were playing to your father and so
we had 30 years we had 10 time better
resolution 10 time better resolution
this means thousand thousand times
smaller volume this means thousand times
more density of information and this is
not a small smaller achievement and and
three point five thirty five to three
point five both these are just number
but three point five mean seeing atoms
and when you see atoms then you are a
chemist and and therefore you have from
cryo-em all the power of chemistry which
means that you see how filaments
aggregates together how you the brain
becomes senile perhaps because of that
you say perhaps you will see how you
will find a drug which will prevent them
to aggregates perhaps now I come to the
onion to my reading now you perhaps we
will understand how to do medicine with
that there are plenty of people who are
interested with results there and
science will continue it will take time
to explore the brain we may understand
understand how we think perhaps
conscience will emerge this is knowledge
without limit oops
yes but knowledge has its consequence
knowledge makes what what our lives are
when the year we discovered we will
publish the Sinn Fein verification
method I got my first personal computer
now now billion 1 billion of people our
city is sitting in front of a computer
screen for most part of their day and
communication between people is
fundamentally change my the father of my
grandfather was living in scarcity
he was never sure to be able to bring
home the minimum required for a decent
life for his family we are now submerged
with access and the world climate is
getting robbed and the glacier just
above our mountain hut is collapsing we
have a problem
Shas sarkozy on sneaker wind alarm this
is not very new roughly 500 years ago
but now it's getting very actual and
very urgent well yes and oh sorry there
is what can we do
it's very urgent what can we do one
thing is certain we scientists must come
out of our ivory tower and be involved
in the society for which we produce
knowledge that knowledge can it can be
equally can have equally good or bad
concept
and we must become more aware and
responsible for these this is the reason
why more than 20 years ago we introduced
in our university a compulsory
curriculum biology and society because
we want our students to be as good
citizen as they are good biologist this
is good but this is not enough how can
we be as good in using our knowledge for
the well-being of all as we are in
producing it I don't know you see we are
used to speak freely but this part is in
some ways too important to be said like
that therefore I want to write it - I
wrote it down and it's make it very
complicated yes I don't know but we must
fight for our most precious good namely
we must protect and fight for the common
the for knowledge knowledge is our
common good and which must make out of
it the best for the well-being of all
now if a future generation imagine
imagine imagine if it's easy if you try
imagine for example we think about else
imagine that we take the w-h-o the World
Health Organization or the organism of
the you know and imagine we and we we
give to this organism all the knowledge
about health and about medicine about
how to help people have and we and we
give this organism the right and the
power to deal to do the best with this
common knowledge of course we will give
those who produce the knowledge the
right where a war reward for the effort
it would not be hard to do
[Music]
but
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]